Hello world, it's Siraj. And
how risky is your credit?
That is the question that we're answering
today by looking at this credit risk
data set.
It is a German credit risk data set.
We want to know based on your employment
history, based on your family history,
your in, you know, your income,
are you at risk for not
paying back your loan?
Usually we have people who do this and
it takes a long time and you have to,
there's a bunch of biases built into the
system. You know, you meet the person,
whether you're an insurance agent or you
work for some bank and you're trying to
assess whether or not this
person deserves alone.
As humans we have a lot of biases and
these biases don't necessarily add real
value to whether or not this person
deserves a loan or not. Right?
So the way to fix that is to let machines
do the job because machines can find
relations in data that we can't.
So the data set we're going to look at
is a bunch of financial attributes of
somebody, the status of their
existing checking account.
This is a German data set by the way.
And I found it on the UCI,
a website also a that is just a
great website to find data sets on.
So definitely check that website
out if you haven't already.
We're going to look at
their credit history,
the duration of payments they've made,
the purchases they made, the cars,
furniture, all of these
things are features, right?
They're all features and we can use that
to assess whether or not this person
has, uh, is at risk for is at risk
for not paying back their loans.
This is used in a bunch of different
fields, insurance of finance, um,
whether or not to rent a
house to somebody, right?
The landlord assesses
whether or not you can pay,
pay it back savings account that
whether or not they're employed,
all these features and the label is,
this is a history of credit risk.
So there's also a label
based on all these features.
This person has already been
assessed as a at risk or not at risk,
right? So that's, that's the
mapping that we're going to learn,
right? It's a, it's a binary mapping.
And the way we're going to do that
is by building a random forest.
That's really the goal here is to learn
about random forests and uh, yeah,
so basically what it would look
like is something like this,
like this picture that
we're looking at right now.
Eventually once we built this a random
forest, which consists of several,
what's what are called decision trees,
it'll look like this.
We'll feed it a new data point and then
it will iteratively ask a series of
questions like,
is there checking account
balance above 200 or below 200?
And then based on that, it'll ask another
set of questions. Like if you say no,
if the answer is no, based on
that data point, you'll say, well,
what's the length of
their current employment?
And then are they credible
or not credible? Right?
So it'll just keep going down this,
this, um, this chain of decisions.
A decision tree. Okay. So that's
what we're going to build.
We're going to build a random forest.
So what is a random forest? Well,
a random forest is a
collection of decision trees.
So let's talk about
what a decision tree is.
So a decision tree is actually
a relatively simple concept,
and so I just didn't even talk
about that in this series so far.
I'm just going straight into random
forests because decision trees are easy
stuff. We want to get right into
the random forest spot, right?
But let's go over decision
trees really quickly.
So a decision tree is basically a set of
decisions on whether or not to classify
something.
The technical name for this
is the classification and
regression tree or cart.
And it was invented by a dude named
Leo Breman, uh, couple of decades ago,
like two decades ago. And it can be
used for both, as the name suggests,
classification and regression,
both of those things.
But we're going to use it for
classification because that is,
that is what we're trying to do,
or we're trying to classify whether or
not someone is credible or not credible.
Okay. So how does this thing work?
Well, you have a set of features, right?
Let's say the features are the
temperature, the wind speed,
and the air pressure. And based
on these three features, uh,
we want to classify whether
or not it's rainy. Well,
what the decision tree that we build
is going to do is it's going to create
iteratively,
be iteratively,
I should say recursively
actually it's going to recurs.
The tree itself is built recursively
you'll see what I mean when I,
when we look at the code,
but the tree itself has built recursively
and for all of these features they
will ask a series of questions until it
classifies it as raining or not raining.
So the real question is how do
we build this thing? What is,
how do we build the optimal tree where
it is asking the rights a threshold
values.
Like how does it know that the temperature
should be greater than or less than
70 degrees Fahrenheit?
And then based on that answer,
how does it know whether the wind speed
should be greater than 4.5 specifically?
Where are these magic numbers coming from?
Well,
they're coming from [inaudible],
the Gini index,
that's what it's called.
It's called the Gini index genie
in a bottle genie in a bottle,
not genie in a bottle. Gd, it's
the Italian Jeannie. So, uh,
it was some dude named Jeanie.
I actually don't know. Uh,
we're not going to get into that.
Anyway, let's talk about the Gini Index.
So the Gini index is
the loss function here.
But the difference here between what we've
done before with grading dissent with
Newton's method is that there is no
convex optimization happening here.
We're not trying to find the
minimum of some convex function.
There is no error that
we're trying to minimize.
The Gini index is a cost
function that works differently.
And here's how it works. Basically for
every single point in our data set, right,
we've got a bunch of different features.
We want to find that
ideal threshold value.
And so I'm going to explain this once and
then explain it again when we get into
the code. But we want to find
that ideal feature, right?
What that ideal value for a feature.
Okay.
So what do I mean by that?
So here's how it works.
Check this out. We've got a Dataset with
a bunch of features, right? 10 features,
right? So one, let's say, let's
say one of them is the income.
So the income could be anywhere,
and I'm gonna use USD for this example.
It could be anywhere from $10,000
a year to $1 million a year.
So what the Gini index is going
to do is it's going to go through,
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
iterate through every single data point
for that feature.
So we're going to say we're
going to iterate through
every single data point and
we're going to compute this Gini index,
which is one minus the sum
of it is the no. So, so the,
the Gini Index is whereas
the formula for it,
it is one,
it is wine minus the average times the
average where the average is proportion,
right? One minus the average of all of
the class values times that average.
And that gives us the Gini Index.
And so what we want to do is it
comes out to some single value.
So I'm a scalar value. And so
basically we use, we start from,
we start from data 0.0 and we go up to
data point and where n is the number of
data points and we compute the index
for each of these data points for a
specific feature,
right?
So let's say the first data point is
10,000 will compute a Gini index for that
data point for that value,
for that amount of income.
And so what happens is
basically it goes on a scale. So
a Gini score of zero is the worst case.
Gini score of zero means that based on
that index for all the other data points
they're gonna be,
they're gonna be evenly split between
less than that value and greater than that
value.
But that's not what we want.
Ideally we want a Gini score of
one that is the ideal Gini core.
And what that means is that for that
given a value that given value for that
specific feature,
all the classes from one,
all the classes from all the data points
from one class will be on one side of
that threshold value.
And all the data points from the other
class will be on the other side of that
threshold value.
That will give us a one value that is
the a one and Jeannie value, right?
And so what we do is we just compute the
Gini index for every single data point
for every single feature. And we just
do that for every feature, right? So we,
so for let's say for income or
Compute, the Gini index all say, okay,
so let's start with 10,000 we'll compare
every other day at point of 10,000 and
see whether it lies on the left or right,
whether it's greater or less than.
And that we get we then we compute
the Gini index from that. Okay.
Which is this formula right here. And
we do that for every single data point.
And so what's gonna happen is we're going
to have a collection of genie indices,
will have a set of Jeannie indices and
then we'll pick the one that is the
highest and the highest one is the one
such that the data points are most our
most uh,
not evenly split.
That means the most data points from
class a are going to be on the left or
right. And the most data point from the
other class will be on the opposite side.
Do you see what I'm saying?
And by side I mean greater
than or less so the,
so the worst genie,
the worst case is when the data points
are evenly split. We don't want that.
We want them to be all on one
side and all on the other side.
That means that when we get a new data
point, it'll plop down right into it's,
it's, it's a little bucket
with all the rest of, it's a
related data points, right?
So that's the Gini index and there are
different measures of a loss when it
comes to
arithmetic based machine learning models.
Instead of Matrix,
a matrix,
operation based machine learning models
like we see with neural networks. Okay,
so that's a Gini score, Gini index,
whatever you want to call it.
So how do we build this decision tree?
Well, it is. There are two parts. We,
first we've got to construct the tree.
So we,
that's a recursive
process that you'll see.
We have to construct the tree
and once we construct the tree,
then we prune the tree.
So that means we identify and remove the
irrelevant branches that might lead to
outliers to increase classification
accuracy. So wait a second,
you might be asking, why are we building
a random forest in the first place?
Why can't we just build a
decision tree alone? Well,
what happens is if you just build a
decision tree, that's not fun. No,
there's a better answer. If you
just build a decision tree, then
your decision tree could be over fit.
That is a big problem when it
comes to decision trees, right?
It's the decision tree gets over fit to
the data, right? It's like, it's like, uh,
the boy,
someone might memorize an eye chart.
It's not like they can see it
properly, right? With one eye closed,
they just memorize the position of where
everything is. Right? In that same way,
we don't want to over fit
for a data to our data.
So the way to prevent that is to create
a bunch of decision trees on random sub
samples of the data. So we'll define
subset, some set of sub samples,
and we'll say for each of these sub
samples we'll create a decision tree.
Then once we have a bunch of decision
trees that we've trained right then by
train,
I mean we've computed the Gini index
for all of the features and then we've
recursively built the tree.
It's a binary tree. By the way,
I didn't mention that the t decision
trees are binary trees right there.
Either I left node or write note or no
node, right? It's the, it's the last node.
And so, um, and if you haven't
reviewed binary trees, I mean,
we're essentially building
a binary tree right now.
But if you want to learn more about data
structures and algorithms or if you're
a curious if you should know
data structures and algorithms
for machine learning,
the answer is yes for two reasons.
One, just for the logic sake,
you need to know how data is stored
because machine learning isn't just about
matrix operations. It's all
also about storing data, right?
Serializing and storing data in the most
efficient way possible and retrieving
it.
And if you want to build algorithms,
you got to have your basic data structure
and algorithm knowledge intact. Okay.
I just wanted to say that back to this,
the way random forest work are each of
the decision trees that are generated.
Then we'll just,
once we have a new data point,
we'll run it through all
of those decision trees.
They'll all make a prediction and then
we'll make a majority vote. So we'll,
we'll calculate a majority vote. So
each of the votes for each of the trees,
whatever the majority vote,
which is the class that is the
class that we're predicting.
And what this does is it gives us higher
accuracy than just using a decision
tree alone.
Let me also say that random forests are
one of the most used machine learning
techniques out there.
They can be because they can be used
for both classification and regression.
And there in lies almost 90 what?
90 plus percent of problems. Right?
And it also works well for very small
data sets, which we tend to have a lot of.
And so that's,
it's so random forest or just use the law.
They're used so much that, how can
I, how can I, how can I say this?
There you so much that the guy,
what's his name? Josh Gordon.
The Google dude,
his name on Twitter is random for us.
So they are very useful. Hi Josh. If
you're watching this. Okay, back to this.
The, okay, so we're training, we're
training it on subsets of data, right?
One subset per tree.
And that is our random forest.
It's a forest because it consists
of trees as you've probably guessed.
And so if you create a giant random
forest, you get lord of the rings.
Rivendale style. No, you don't,
you, the bigger, the better.
Generally you'll see at the end,
the more trees we add,
the better our accuracy
score gets, right? So yeah,
in each of our nodes are going to
represent a set of feature splits. Right?
So what's the color green?
Red. Green. Okay. What's the
size? Small. Big. Big. Okay.
That fruit is a watermelon, right?
So we just recursively do that.
Are there other good examples of this you
might be asking? And the answer is yes,
of course there are other good examples.
The stock price,
prediction and classification.
I've got two great examples here.
Definitely check them out.
The documentation is pretty sparse,
but the code itself, it's not using any
libraries. So definitely check it out.
All right,
so now the,
let's go into the order of functions
that we're going to follow.
So we're not gonna have time
to write every single function.
We're not using any libraries,
but we will write the two most
important functions split and get split.
And that's going to really take, take
on the majority of our, uh, logic.
But that's what we're going to do.
And that's going to be 40 lines of code,
but for the rest of it,
this is the order of functions that I'm
going to follow the chain of functions.
So let's just get right down into what
this chain of functions will look like.
So I'm going to first of all
look at our dependencies here.
So I'm going to import seed from random
and feed is going to generate pseudo
random numbers.
This is useful for debugging.
You want to do it anytime you have some
random numbers and you want to debug
your code and production or otherwise.
It's always great to have some seed
so that the random numbers that are
generated start from the
same point every time.
And so that's just great for
reproducibility of results.
Or I'm also going to import rand range is,
so it's going to return a
randomly selected element
from a range of numbers, CSV,
because our Dataset is, by the way,
let me, let's see. Our dataset,
our Dataset is a CSV file.
It our Dataset is a CSV file.
So let's open our dataset
and see what it looks like.
It is the numeric data right here,
right?
So all of it is numeric at the end.
The result is either two or one, right?
It's a binary level, either two or
one, and the rest are like 15 features.
Here we're going to use every single
one of them, no features election.
We're going to use every single
one of these features. Okay?
And it's using arithmetic so
that we're only importing math.
We're not even importing num Pi. We're
only importing the math library. Okay,
so let's,
let's look at this thing.
So we've got some really basic data
loader functions here. Load CSV,
initialize a Dataset,
has a list,
open it as a readable file
initialize a CSV reader,
and then for every row in the dataset
appended to this Dataset Matrix,
it's a two d matrix. Return it. And so
we have an in memory version of our data.
We know that part that's, that's, that's
general to all machine learning really.
Whenever you're reading a CSP fall,
what else do we have here?
We have two more helper methods functions.
One to convert a column to
an inch and one to convert,
one to convert a string to an aunt
and one to convert an into a stream.
And that's if we have string values.
But in this case we don't,
we have numerical value so we don't
need this. Okay, so let's go into this.
This order that I was talking about, the
order of algorithms. So the first, um,
so the first one went to look at
is this main code here, right?
So we started off with the seeds
so that we always start with the,
with the same random numbers.
We loaded up our Dataset, right?
That CSV file and then we
converted our strings to integers.
We don't actually need to do
that. But then we said, okay,
so how many folds do we want to have?
And folds means sub samples of data.
So we want five sub samples.
What is the nax depth?
And the depth means how many nodes,
what is the depth of the tree, right?
How many levels of that tree
do we want to create through,
we're going to say Max 10 levels.
And these are our hyper parameters.
We can tune them, we can make them more
or less, and we'll have different results.
They're kind of like note the number
of neurons in a neural network, right?
And so we say,
what's the minimum size?
What's the minimum size for each of those
nodes? How many features do we have?
We'll count all of those as well.
And then what we're gonna do is we're
going to create three different random
forests, or we're going to create
one random forest with just one tree.
So it's actually a decision tree.
And then one with five trees
and then one with 10 trees.
And then we'll assess and then we'll
assess how good each of these random
forests are by measuring
the number of trees,
the accuracy score for each of them.
Okay? That's what we're going to do.
So notice that here is
the big boy right here.
This evaluate algorithm is that main
function that we're going to use to train
our model. So we're going to give
evaluate algorithm, our dataset.
We're going to give it the,
the random forest model that we've built,
the number of folds or the sub samples of
the data, how big we want to treat a, B,
the mid size, the sample
size, the number of trees,
and the number of features
that we've counted.
So let's look at what this evaluates
how rhythm function looks like,
because that's really the big boy,
right?
We want to see what is going on in this
main, this big function right here.
So what I'll do is I will go right here.
Okay.
So what it's doing is it's going to say
this, let's look at this. Okay, ready?
Let's, let's look at this. What it's
gonna do is it's going to say, okay,
so for a given dataset
and for a given algorithm,
which is the random forest algorithm
that we're going to feed it,
let's say the folds are the sub samples
that are used to train and validate our
models.
So we'll split our data into a
training and a validation set,
um, by the number of folds. So
what do I mean by that? Well. Okay,
let's look at that cross validation split
method. Where is that? It's right here.
So, so we basically want to
split the data into cables.
The original sample is randomly
partitioned into k equal size sub samples.
And then of those case sub samples,
a single sub sample is retained as the
validation data and the rest are going to
be used for training data.
It's splitting the data so that k minus
one sub samples are used for training.
And then there's one sub sample that's
left for validation. That's it. Okay.
So back to this, we talked
about, uh, that function.
So once we've split our data into those
folds, then we're going to say, okay,
let's score each of them,
right?
Because we're evaluating
our random forest algorithm.
So we'll say for each of the sub
samples that we have of our data,
let's create a copy of the data and
then remove the given subsample.
We'll initialize a test set because
this algorithm really does two things.
It try it,
it trains our model on the training data
and then it tests it out on the testing
data. That is, it makes predictions on
the testing data, ignoring the labels.
So we'll say okay for each.
So we'll add each row in a
given sub sample to the test
set so that we have test
samples as well. And then we'll get
the predicted label, right, so for,
so we'll use a random forest algorithm.
This,
this is our random force algorithm that
that's the next thing we're going to
look at. But it's going to get all the
predicted labels from them, right? For,
from our training and our testing set.
And then it'll get the actual labels,
right? So, and once it has the predicted
labels and it has the actual labels,
then it can compare the two
via this accuracy metric.
And the accuracy metric is a scalar value
and it is how we assess the validity
of every random forest that we've built.
And so the accuracy metric to go into
this is really simple for each label.
If the actual label matches
the predicted label,
add one to the correct iterator and
then we just calculate the percentage of
predictions that were correct, which
is the number of them divided by the,
the number of correct divided
by the actual ones times
a hundred. Really simple.
Like I said, it's all arithmetic.
It's all plus minus, plus minus,
multiply and divide. That's all this is.
There's, there's no linear Algebra here.
It's all Algebra. Um, so, but
despite how simple this model it is,
it is quite powerful, which
is why it's awesome. Okay,
so that's our evaluate algorithm
function. So let's keep going down, right?
We're going down the chain, go into
the Moon, Moon Ride, Moon Ride,
Moon ride mood. I'm just adding my
crazy aunt as well. So back to this,
if you got that referenced,
you're cool.
If you didn't get their references
from spongebob back to this,
you're still cool. So back to this, so
we're evaluating our algorithm here.
Let's evaluate this thing.
So if we're evaluating our algorithm,
so what does this algorithm function even
do? What, what is this? Right? Let's,
let's see what this algorithm function is.
What this algorithm function is,
is it is our random forest.
That is what it is.
We say for the range
of trees that we have,
let's compute a subsample of those trees.
And then for that sub sample we'll
build a specific decision tree for that
specific sub sample.
And then once we built that tree,
we'll add it to our list of trees and
then we're going to make predictions based
on all of those trees and we'll return
the list. The predictions right?
Seems simple enough, right? So
what does this bagging predict?
Now notice how we're, we just keep
going down the chain, right? We,
we just keep going down the chain.
So this is the list of trees
responsible for making a prediction for,
with each decision tree.
So it combines a predictions from each
decision tree and we select the most
common prediction, the one that
comes up the most, that that label,
that the sum of that label is greater
than the rest. The, some of the others,
right? And there are only two labels
because this is binary classification.
You can also do
multi-class classification,
but we're not going to talk
about that right now. Okay.
So then we've talked about
bagging predict. So what's
next? Sub Sample, right?
Where does this the sub sample function?
So how are we sub sampling?
How are we choosing how to split this
data? Right? That's the question.
How are we choosing how to do
that? Well, the answer is we are,
we are creating a random subsample and
this is where our randomness comes in,
right? We are creating a random subsample
in this random range for the number of
samples and the data and we'll add that
list of sub samples to this sample array
and then return that.
So the sample array or list contains
all of those samples from our,
from our Dataset, right? We split
them. And so that's for sub sampling.
And so now where were we? Oh,
so we talked about sub sampling,
the building tree part. Let's, let's
see how the tree itself is built.
So if we give it some sub sample,
the depth and size of the tree,
that's too hyper parameters as
well as the number of features.
We expect this function to build
this tree, so let's look at how this,
how this function works. How is
it building the tree itself? Well,
inside of this function we
said we noticed that it's,
it's first using this method gets split,
which we're going to code and which
is where the meat of the code goes,
but we're going to build a,
and that involves creating the root node
and that's going to get that split and
that that's going to this, this is
going to output the root node, right?
That that first node and then we'll call
the split function that's going to call
itself recursively to build out,
build out the whole tree.
So once we've got that root node,
then we're going to call split
recursively and so it's just going to
continuously build that tree
recursively by calling itself.
In case you haven't heard of recursion,
it's when a function calls itself,
it's like inception, except
it's recursion. Yeah. Wow.
I never actually made that reference
until I just said that, right?
Inception is recursion
a dream inside a dream.
Whoa. Okay. Back to this.
Um, right. Uh, right.
So where were we? Uh, so we were
at split and get split. So let's,
let's write out get split,
right?
So get split is the first one
that we want to write out.
This is going to select the best
split point in a Dataset, right? That,
that key question.
How do we know when to split our data
in this decision tree of the many
decisions trees that we
make in our random forest?
The answer is we'll have
to compute it this way.
This is an exhaustive
and greedy algorithm.
That means it is just going to go through
every single iteration that it can,
right? There are no heuristics
here. There's no educated guesses,
there are no educated guesses.
It's going to go through every single
data point to compute that split.
So let's look at what this looks like.
Well, we've got to give it, first of all,
our Dataset of course. And we want to
give it the number of features, right?
Because for each of those features,
we're going to compute that split.
So given a data set,
we got to check every value on each
attribute as a candidate split.
So we're gonna,
what we're gonna do is we're going to
say let's get all of those class values
right and that, that, that set of
class values is going to be a list.
That set of class values is going to be
a list and it's going to be a list for
every single data point.
And so we'll save all of the rows from
our dataset are our data points, right?
We have that,
we know that
we want to calculate the
index, the value, the score,
and the groups can.
So
we'll initialize all of these as really
big numbers and they will be updated
with time, but we'll initialize them
as very big numbers as well. Okay,
so check this out.
So the Gini Index,
essentially it gives us two things. It
gives us an index and it gives us a value,
the index of the feature of the
feature of the, so it gives us the,
it gives us the index of some feature
whose value is the optimal value to split
the data on for that feature.
Do you see what I'm saying?
It gives us the index of say for income,
let's say that 30,000 is the best feature
is going to be that decision node.
From then we can split everything
based on 30,000 that is where the,
the classes are most split. It's going
to give us the index of 30,000 in the,
in the Dataset as well as the
value, whatever it is, 30,000 right?
So that's the pair that
the Gini index gives us,
the index and the value and it will also
give us a score and the groups and the
groups are the sub samples. And the score
is the, is is how good it is, right?
It's a measure of how good it is.
So we all want to initialize our features
here as a list and then we're going to
say, okay, so while the
yeah,
number of features is less than,
uh,
the number of features,
whereas this is going to be zero and we're
going to increase it every time as we
iterate through each of the features.
Well,
let's see this decide some
random range, right? Some,
some random index in our
dataset to then to a pen,
to our features list.
So we'll say if the index
is not in the features,
which it won't be then a pen at first,
but eventually it will,
will append,
it will append the index wherever we
are to the list of features that we
initialize is empty.
And then
once we've done that, we'll say, um,
yeah,
every index in the Dataset for
each of those indices, let's,
let's go through every
single row in the datasets.
So we're competing groups here,
right?
So we're competing groups to split
our data into, so we're saying, well,
we want to decide the,
the test values that we want
to split as well as the, um,
the Gini Index.
And so the Gini index is what
we're computing right here.
This is the point that we're computing
are Gini index for the current group of
data that we're in, right? So for,
for we've picked a feature and we're going
to iterate through every row for that
feature.
We're going to compute the Gini index for
all of those values and we're going to
pick the GDN decks. That is the,
that is the, uh, largest, right?
And that is what we're going for.
And that once we picked the
genie and Nexatus largest,
that will give us the index and value to
then build out that, that note of this,
the decision tree. Okay. So then, um,
we've computed that and then
we're going to say, okay,
if the Gini index is less
than the optimal score, uh,
then we want to say we're going to
update these values to the new values,
to the score,
the value of the index and the groups.
Okay.
So we're going to use a dictionary to
store the node in the decision tree by its
name. So we'll say return, where were we?
So we'll say return the index.
Okay.
As well as the value,
the value and
the groups, the groups, right?
So we went to index the
value in the groups, right?
Cause we've computed all those, right?
So this, that function gives us,
gives us the root node, right?
And so once we have the root node,
then we can actually
perform the splitting,
write it down the best flooding point.
And so now we want to recursively
compute this splitting itself.
So that's where our split function
comes in. Given that root node,
how do we build the tree such that it
is split along the ideal aligns. Okay,
so let's, let's see. Let's write out this
split function. Okay, so it's going to,
so basically, so this is the
binary tree part. If you've,
if you've created a binary tree before
it is exactly the same. So given some,
uh, root node, right,
we're going to say some root node will
compute a left and right leaf for that
node. And then we'll delete the
original node. So we'll say, okay,
so now we can delete that.
And then
once we've done that,
we can check if either the left
or right group of nodes is empty.
So we're checking if either the left note
or the right note is empty. And if so,
then we create a terminal node using the,
the, the records that we do have here,
right? So an a terminal node. By the way,
let's look at what a terminal note is.
We select a class value for a group of
rows and then return the most common
output value in that list of rose.
What is the most common health
put value in that list of rose.
And that is the most common class.
So that's what we're doing.
We're selecting the most common
class. Okay? So that's the first part.
And so we want to check if we've
reached our maximum depth, right?
So that that depth is our hyper parameter
is a threshold for how large we want
our tree to be. So we'll check if we've,
if we've reached that point. So we'll say,
um,
if the depth is greater than
or equal to the Max depth,
then
so if we reached our Max depth and then
we create a terminal node, that's what,
that's what that's saying. Okay. So then,
um, we've, we've got two more parts here.
All right, so the next
part is to say, okay,
so first the two groups of data
that are split by the node,
we retrieved them when we store them
in the left and rights variables here.
And then we delete that node.
Then we check if either the left or the
right group of is empty. And if they are,
we create a terminal node using the
records that we already have right here.
And so the terminal node by the way,
is where we just select the class
value that's the most used, right?
And that is the, that is the output class.
The output class, the terminal node.
Is that, what is that? What is the,
what is the prediction itself? Right?
So that's the end point. And
so then, um, we check if,
so then we check if either the
left or right group of roses empty.
And if so we create
that terminal and road.
So then we check if we've
reached our maximum depth.
And if so we create a terminal node. And
so that's what this part is. And then,
and so lastly,
if the group of rows is too small,
we'll create a terminal node else.
We'll add the left node in a depth first
fashion until the bottom of the tree
has reached on.
This branch will do this.
So we'll do the same for
the right child as well.
And so the right side is
in process in the same way.
And then as we rise back up to construct
a tree all the way back up to the route.
Okay,
so get split.
Notice how gets split has been
called here over and over again. Uh,
two more functions and then, and
then we're, we're good with this.
The two more functions I had where the
Gini index and so the Gini index is like
I said, it is, it was that
formula right up here. Okay.
This is the Gini index or Gini Score,
whatever you want to call it.
So the Gini index splits a
dataset involving one input
feature and one value for
that feature, right? What the Gini index
gives us is remember that pair that,
that the value and the
index of some feature, some
features for some data points,
right? And that's, that's the line
that we then split or that's the,
the boundary from which we can split
database on that feature in the future.
And so the way we compute
that is it starts off at zero.
It's some scalar value and we're
computing it for all of the data points.
So for each class value that we have for
all of our classes and we only have two
fraudulent or not fraudulent,
um,
and we only have two credit worthy or
not credit worthy for each of those
classes, we'll select a
random subset of that class,
will compute the average
value for that feature. Um,
and then will compute p times one minus
p where p is the average and that is our
genie scaler. Okay. And we'll,
we'll add them all up together because
we have all of those cause it's the sum
of all of those values and that's where
the sigma notation comes in and will
return that as a Gini score. Okay.
And we compute that for all of,
that's the subsets of our data.
And so the last function to show you
is the predict function and the predict
function is right here,
right? So when, whenever we're
actually making predictions,
this is how it works, it navigates
down the tree. This is asking,
is this person employed or nuts
with this person? Go to school.
What is this person's social security
number? What does this person, you know,
just a bunch of random
questions based on the features.
Each of the features that we
have so predict is recursive.
So whereas the node is always
changing for a given row,
the node could be the left
note or the right node.
So whether or not the value for some data
point is the less than or greater than
some nodes, threshold value that
we've computed using the Gini index,
it will then update the node and then use
that as the new parameter to then run,
predict again. And eventually once it's
reach the terminal node, the last node,
the label, it will return the label
and that and we, and then because,
and that's for one decision tree.
And because we have a random forest,
it's computing that for
every single decision tree
we sum up the values and then
we use the one that is the majority vote.
And that is our prediction.
So then if we test our code,
we'll notice that the, uh,
we've got our, uh, accuracy scores
here. And so the accuracy is getting,
is improving every time. So we've tried
it for three different random forests.
We tried it, we tried it for
one with one decision tree.
We tried it for one with five decision
trees and we tried to it for one with 10
decision trees. And every time the
accuracy accuracy score improved.
And so what this means is
if we give it a 100, uh,
100 tree random forest or a thousand
tree forest, it's going to do really,
really well. Okay? So, uh,
and then we'll be able to predict whether
or not someone's someone is worthy of
getting their credit assessed or not. And
if you made it to the end of this, um,
I'm very happy. So thank
you. And that's all.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to do something random.
So thanks for watching.